where else do you want to travel outside
of tokyo because you've only just been
in tokyo you kind of went to osaka but
you didn't really get to explore it much
so go back to nara and feed the deer
um i want to trace your footsteps yeah i
want to go to hokkaido because i hear
the food is really good dude yes you've
never been max food yeah yeah bro you
don't even know you don't even know
and i want to go to a uh ryokan
i mean yeah oh yeah yeah that's a must
that's a mouse
yeah yeah yeah really really good ones
yeah it sucks because you can pay a lot
of money and it can be mid you can pay
like the same amount of money it could
be like the most insane amazing ryokan
ever so so if you don't like it the
first time i wouldn't say don't write it
off just because you've had one like if
you ever have one mid one it literally
just depends
and like some of them are insane some of
them are
overpriced yeah yeah yeah melin told us
that i don't know died has told us that
melon forced you to buy some premium
strawberries
were they worth it she loves strawberry
you love strawberries did i buy premium
strawberries well you went strawberry
picking right yeah
well they weren't that expensive
i mean they can be though have you
bought any of the expensive ones
i think the most expensive strawberries
i bought were like nine bucks so how
many
for like
nine
that's quite a lot yeah one dollar a
store so good strawberries are so good
here when they're in season and you're
that's your favorite right you're
obsessed with strawberries see okay they
were already one of my favorites when i
lived in the states but like
strawberries in the states kind of suck
yeah because they're like hollow
they're hard and they're kind of sad
yeah cut one open
well it's just gonna be a [ __ ] like
nothing
it's just not nothing but it's there's
like a little bit of space in there and
it's like not just like an air pocket
yeah there's something really what the
[ __ ] is going on in the u.s how do you
even do that and it's not juicy i mean
i'm sure there's some strawberries that
are juicy but i
once if you get like a carton of
strawberries from the supermarket you
can expect them to just be sour hard and
yeah so you never get like good ones in
america
you must do because you like
strawberries all right
where'd you get your lovely strawberries
from that [ __ ] there
i like strawberries but usually like
oftentimes i would have to eat it with
like a little bit of nutella
because it's like missing that like
extra sweetness
like you put whipped cream on it to get
that bit of sweetness so like in the
states i love strawberries on things
yeah but in japan i remember i tried
doing the nutella thing it's way too
sweet right yeah yeah yeah the
strawberries here are so like succulent
and
juicy and sweet yeah and oh my god [ __ ]
it already
it is so good i'm gonna miss it it's
already out of season i miss it already
i wanted to buy like those luxury like
fruit gift boxes to bring today oh yeah
yeah
problem is
uh strawberries are not in season
anymore yeah so they don't have any of
like the super nice good ones
is that why you asked me what my
favorite fruit is
okay i was just like why didn't you
bring my my favorite fruit because i do
i guess luxury bananas aren't a thing i
guess that's just like the peasants
that's a jojo fan dream dude
wait what did you say i said strawberry
as well and emily was like nice choice
and like they only sell like they sell
some kind of like premium bananas but it
was like in a single you can get like
premium like watermelon that's your
favorite right i chose warm milk i can't
just buy the watermelon
fruit and then i was like damn it what
do i do oh maybe i'll get like something
shareable
well
that's the thing i didn't i ended up not
getting anything because i saw a box of
cherries for like two hundred dollars
and i just walked out
two hundred dollars for a box of
cherries how many
there were cherries just
bunch of cherries the golden
giant cherry
i could have gotten because they were
they were selling like mini watermelon
for like 50 bucks oh yeah yeah oh i
could get joey watermelon but then for
the strawberries they were only selling
these like premium strawberries that
were like single packed yeah and i'm
like i can't just give one strawberry
no you definitely should have that'll be
hilarious
is the square
watermelon thing a thing yeah definitely
oh i've never seen the square
watermelons they're not edible no they
are aren't they no they're not edible
they must be no they're absolutely
what's the [ __ ] point in making them
not edible why would they make
they are the boys they looked it up on
google and they were like yeah they're
not edible people just buy them for
decoration no i've definitely eaten
water
i mean i'm googling this right now
they're just like a watermelon this just
has a funny shape oh it's like it's like
a [ __ ] minecraft interesting fact
emily can you can you give a source to
back it up
i mean i it was quite a what the [ __ ]
yeah this one says square watermelons
which are harvested while still unripe
are not edible and are purchase
generally as ornaments see what the [ __ ]
did i eat
someone like a regular watermelon that's
obviously shaped out yeah do you fall
asleep because my whole thing is that
like i like i do enjoy watermelon i do
find the shape really annoying yeah like
it's it's kind of like the round shirt
yes i'm trying to store a balloon
somewhere it's like it doesn't really
like pack well into the fridge so why
why would they have square watermelons
if they're not edible then i don't know
japan i don't know why why is why is the
kernel for christmas [ __ ]
like [ __ ] play minecraft once and
it's because the colonel looks like
santa
can i confess the other reason why i
ended up not getting the fancy fruit
i was terrified that you guys would
taste it and you'd be like yeah it just
tastes like a strawberry
but you would never you never get to you
never get to get the highs without the
lows right yeah yeah okay okay here's
how they taste the difference is there a
difference i don't know
because here's the thing i have actually
because strawberry is my favorite fruit
i have
bought a single strawberry once for five
dollars
um and it was like one of those like
giant strawberries yeah and i saw it and
i'm just like i gotta try it man yeah i
i gotta try i'm just like it's it was
like it was like it was a strawberry
like
kind of like it was it was like massive
it was like that big yeah kind of like
that that's a pretty big size of a
strawberry so it was about the size of
like three strawberries packed together
it was like five dollars i was like i
gotta try it
it was just a strawberry it was a very
very good strawberry it was just like
high like
the the volume of it was [ __ ] massive
i've never taken such a big fight on the
single strawberry but it of the
strawberry what did you expect like the
most
the moment you bit into it your balls
explode
you just come yeah yeah
that's it i i went to a bar the other
day and uh in this bar it was like a
small bar
and there was a strawberry seller at the
bar right so he brought strawberries for
everyone what is this like a jrpg it's
like the productions just hitting the
ball
she was in the bar and i walked in i was
there and he was just like yeah everyone
he wants to give all the people at the
bar strawberries all right so
it was a whole pack and they were big
yeah they were [ __ ] big yeah and i
was like all right i mean i just had a
big dinner but i guess i could eat a
strawberry yeah they gave me like five
in a bowl and i i was like jesus christ
i feel like matt stone where's this bar
i don't know if he's there every night
though yeah emily's just going to count
i'm like i'm not hungry so i eat one and
then they're like you have to you'd
finish them all it's it's like root
strawberries
and i'm like
like you said like this [ __ ] big one
of the strawberries are [ __ ] giant
yeah they're free yeah it was fun
i was i was but you ever watched matilda
no you've anyone watched matilda the
movie no [ __ ] sake dude it's like a
british it's like no it's american it's
but it's roll down so it's wrong roll
down something i don't know a [ __ ]
thing i think rodell
was british
right no yeah he is british yeah but the
matilda movie would uh with danny devito
uh is is american you know there's a
scene where where they forced the kid to
like eat all this chocolate cake oh yeah
yeah yeah i remember that yeah and
that's what it felt like i was like oh
he's so it's delicious but i'm so full
oh
i don't know like yeah it would have
been your like [ __ ] heaven though
yeah yeah that was me strawberry picking
with me lean we ate so many that like
we were so full maylene was like i'm
nauseous and then the very nice
strawberry farmer guy came up and was
like oh i got some white and pink straw
here you go do you like the white ones
yeah do you like the white ones they're
cute i prefer the red ones yeah the
white ones don't really have much taste
it looks sick it's like a like a shiny
pokemon it's yeah it's like a dragon
fruit it looks so cool but it doesn't
taste like anything yeah
anyway i don't know what i was gonna say
i thought you're gonna say something
like
i was i was being like yeah what do i
need what do i what can i add to white
strawberries i don't know they look like
a ssr drop of strawberries i guess